I wanna stress the importance of reading
how many of you guys enjoy reading yeah
yeah they have a really really great
teacher who was completely committed and
passionate about teaching young kids and
inspiring and he actually built the
curriculum around one of the shows that
I created called the peonies and we got
wind of it and decided to pop it for a
surprise visit and and check out his
classroom and see how these kids get
inspired by the Pew T's is the test
how anime oh that's shat
how much better than the rest
[Music]
it's the teacher the teacher is you know
it's such an important role that we have
that tends to get overlooked within our
society but it's such a huge
responsibility and he's done a
phenomenal job inspiring this kids
learning in ways that they learn best so
sometimes that's a creative way with art
I've had so many different uses in my
life from my parents at a very early age
to teachers I still have a teacher that
I hold dear and her name is Jane
Mastriano I still hold her dear the most
important people that I found in my life
with his family and your teachers and
coaches are used to when I first started
then the more I practice the less and
less nervous I became I love being
around kids it's fine I mean it's you
know this is why we create stories and
content for children they're so fun to
be around
there's so much knowledge that we want
to share with them
[Laughter]
well seeing their face light up if
something that's entertaining or an idea
that they capture you see their
imagination working assistant it's
enjoyable to be around so any chance I
did to come and talk to kids and share
these stories with them I'm all for it